Nicht nur der Weltraum, sondern auch die Tiefen
unserer Ozeane sind noch weitestgehend unerforscht.
Doch es werden immer mehr Hightech-Geräte
entwickelt, die auch in vielen tausend Metern
Tiefe funktionieren.
Beispielsweise im Südpazifik - konkret im
sogenannten Atacamagraben - rund 150 Kilometer
von der Küste Chiles und Peru entfernt.
In unfassbaren 8.000 Kilometern Tiefe herrschen
extremer Druck und eisige Kälte.
Eigentlich keine guten Bedingungen für Leben.
Doch jetzt hat ein britisches Forschungsteam
genau dort eine geisterhafte Entdeckung gemacht
und spannende Details zum Leben an den tiefsten
Orten der Erde gewonnen.
Herzlich willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, damit ihr nichts verpasst.
Er ist lang und geleeartig.
Seine Haut ist durchsichtig und seine Bewegungen
sind geschmeidig.
Die Rede ist vom sogenannten Schneckenfisch.
Drei bislang noch unbekannte Arten des Schneckenfischs
konnte ein Forschungsteam Newcastle University
jetzt im Atacamagraben aufspüren.
Einer der tiefsten Orte der Erde überhaupt!
Und die Filmaufnahmen dieser bisher unbekannten
Arten in blau, lila und pink sind wirklich
einzigartig.
Der Lebensraum der Tiere ist der Tiefseegrund
- genau genommen in einer Tiefe von 6.400
Metern.
Und die Lebensbedingungen da unten sind extrem.
Es herrscht nicht nur ein extremer Druck,
sondern auch extreme Kälte.
Doch nicht nur das.
Eines der Exemplare konnten die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler sogar “bergen” - zwar
im toten Zustand, aber immerhin.
Das ermöglicht es dem Team jetzt, den Fisch
im Labor genauer unter die Lupe zu nehmen.
Doch schon jetzt steht fest, dass sich die
Tiere optimal an die extremen Lebensbedingungen
in der Tiefsee angepasst haben.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Thomas
Linley: “Ihre geleeartige Struktur macht
es ihnen möglich, sich perfekt an den extremen
Druck anzupassen”.
Da ihr Körper sehr empfindlich ist, würden
die Tiere sogar ohne den Druck und die Kälte
sterben.
Ja tatsächlich: Sie würden bei wärmeren
Temperaturen sogar schmelzen.
Laut des Forschungsteams sind die Knochen
in ihren Innenohren die härtesten Strukturen
in ihrem ganzen Körper.
Kurioserweise entsprechen die Schneckenfische
nun mal so gar nicht dem Klischee der Tiefseefische,
die man im Kopf haben könnte.
Denn er ist weder besonders imposant, noch
hat er Schuppen oder gar große Zähne.
Dennoch scheint es den Fischen sehr gut in
dieser extremen Tiefe zu gehen.
Denn sie befinden sich außerhalb der Reichweite
von anderen Fischen und haben somit keine
Konkurrenten.
Futter dagegen gibt es reichlich.
Auch das ist eine Erkenntnis, die das britische
Forschungsteam bei der Exkursion in 6.500
Meter Tiefe gewinnen konnte.
Manche Bereiche in dieser Region sind übrigens
bis zu 11.000 Meter tief.
Und genau deswegen sind diese Gebiete weitestgehend
auch immer noch unerforscht.
Das Hightech-Gerät der britischen Universität
war auf einer Art Lander befestigt worden
- mit HD-Kameras und Fallen ausgestattet worden.
Dann dauert es einige Stunden, bis das Gerät
auf den Meeresboden gesunken ist.
Dann konnten Videoaufnahmen gemacht werden
und Proben gesammelt werden.
Bei der letzten Expedition des britischen
Forschungsteams entstanden mehr als 100 Stunden
Videomaterial und knapp 11.500 Fotos.
Und der Schneckenfisch war nicht die einzige
Überraschung, die die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler dadurch zu Gesicht bekamen.
Seltene Aufnahmen entstanden auch von langbeinigen
Asseln, die in extra so groß sind wie eine
erwachsene Hand - mit kleinem Körper, aber
extrem langen Beinen… Die Tiere schwimmen
rückwärts, dann richten sie sich am Meeresboden
auf und breiten ihre langen Beine aus wie
eine Spinne.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher: “ Es
ist unglaublich, sie in ihrem natürlichen
Lebensraum in Aktion zu sehen - besonders
toll ist der Move, den sie machen, wenn sie
vom Schwimmen zum Gehen wechseln.”
Wenn ihr wirklich kein Video verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert auch den englischen Kanal.
Da gibt es die ein oder andere Videopremniere
und ihr könnt mit mir euer englisch verbessern
oder es euren englischen Freunden und Freundinnen
empfehlen.
Hier geht es auch direkt weiter mit „Frankensteins
heirs: researchers create human-rat hybrid
beings“ Viel Spaß damit und bis dann bleibt
dran!